hello everyone my name is komal jain
and i work as director of bioinformatics
at the center for infection and immunity
at columbia university irving medical
center
welcome to my talk i hope you are
staying safe and doing well
today i am going to talk about
development of capture sequencing assays
for enhanced detection and genotyping
of tick bond pathogens and infectious
vertebrate viruses
the first part of my talk is about dvd
capsic it's an 11 plex diagnostic assay
for tick bond diseases
recently we published it in scientific
reports and if you're interested in more
information please check it out
some of the common illnesses caused by
ticks include lyme disease which is
caused by bacterium borrelia burglar
ferrari
and rarely borrelia mayonnaise typical
symptoms include fever headache fatigue
and a characteristic skin rash called
erythrina migrants
it is the most common vector-borne
disease in the united states it is
transmitted to humans through the bite
of infected black-legged texts
anaplasmosis or and early chooses are
also two closely related tick-bone
diseases which are caused by anaplasma
and likia respectively
and they are also transmitted to humans
by the bite of an infected tick
vabesia is a parasite that causes
obediosis and it infects red blood cells
causing malaria-like symptoms
in addition to transmission via tick the
bezier can be transmitted from mother to
unborn child
or through a contaminated blood
transfusion
lyme disease diagnostics suffers from
many limitations
unlike anaplasma and babesia that have
diagnostic molecular assays the assays
for lyme disease detection
suffers from low sensitivity and
therefore serology is the primary method
for diagnosing lyme disease
so the issue with the serology based
essays are that
it can lead to false positives because
eliza test for lyme disease is highly
sensitive
and it can
lead to false positives from
diseases like syphilis autoimmune
disorders such as lupus
tick bond elapsing fever and
anaplasmosis
and it can also lead to false negatives
because an individual may not have
developed antibodies at the time
at the time of testing
and
also if an individual is
immunocompromised has co-infection or
another illness
false negatives are likely
so in order for
lyme disease to be diagnosed both elisa
and western loss test must be positive
and both of these tests are indirect
methods of diagnosis
they do not detect the actual 9 disease
bacterium
so therefore we designed this uh tbd
capsic method
where we you we can
directly
uh
we can make the diagnosis based on
nucleic acid as opposed to serology so
the
this is how the probes were designed
we took the
entire nucleotide sequences of
every genomic segment
of
these 11 agents which resulted in
106 plasmid and chromosomal sequences
to account for high degree of
heterogeneity in borrelia burgdorferi
sensor structural species we included
three strains representing disparate of
three gene types
and the final probes that consisted of
400 000
probe sequences and it was manufactured
by roche
these are the agents that are included
in dbd capsic 11-plex assay there are
three borrelia species titabesia and a
plasma erikia
two decades of species and two viruses
namely bovacin and heartland virus
so we conducted a series of experiments
to validate these probes
and the first experiment consisted of
three c3h mice that were infected with
n40 strain of borrelia burgdorferi
from each of these three mice
heart ear and bladder tissues
were obtained and two deplete larval
ticks fed on these mice were also used
in the experiment this resulted in a
total of 11 samples which were sequenced
using
unbiased sequencing as well as tbd
capsic
so the table here shows the results from
this experiment and the first column are
the samples and the second columns are
the ct values from rtpcr
and here we can see the normalized reads
from pbd catholic and the normalized
streets from unbiased high throughput
sequencing
we can see that there's a range of ct
values
low ct values means high pathogen burden
and
high ct values mean low pathogen burden
and the last column here shows the fold
enrichment
what we can see here is that
for
low ct values as well as high ct values
the recovery of the
borrelia
from
tbd capsic is pretty good and the full
enrichment ranges from 140 to
9332
and even when
the
sample is not detectable
from qpcr we are still able to detect it
from tbd capsic and the performance is
much superior to unbiased high
throughput sequencing
the second experiment used three c 57
black fixed mice one was infected with
n40 strain of beryllium for eye one with
b31 strain and one was infected with
both
from each of these three mice we
extracted heart ear bladder and ankle
tissues
and two replete larval texts were used
of these two larval texts one was a
negative control
a total of 14 samples and a negative
control were used the negative control
was the salmon sperm sample
and they were sequenced using unbiased
sequencing and dbd catholic
this table here shows the results from
this particular experiment
in the first column we can see the ct
values again as before there's a range
of ct values and the high ct values
means low pathogen burden
and
these are not detectable from pcr so
what we can see for these samples is
the results from both unbiased and dbd
capsic
and we can see clearly that a lot of
these samples were not called
from unbiased sequencing but they are
detectable
uh from
dbd cad seek
and we can see the
fold enrichment is pretty high
ranging from
100 to
like 52 000 which is a pretty high
number so even with very high ct values
such as 35 34 33 dbd capsic did a good
job of detecting the pathogen
one thing to keep in mind is
that there's an imbalance of leads here
uh and some of the samples have
more reads than
the other samples for example this low
ct sample
has 64 million reads
and
this stick sample
also has 63 million reads
so
basically uh
this caused fewer reads to be assigned
to other samples and if we can play
around with um sample preparation and
library preparation protocols
and cod cause this distribution to be
more homogeneous we can actually correct
for this bias in the rate distribution
and
since the negative samples are correctly
identified as negative
positive samples are correctly
identified as positive that's both
sensitivity and specificity of this
essay is pretty good these reeds here
are the ribosomal rna reads that map to
other bacteria
and
this schematic here shows the mappings
of the
reach to the genomes of the b31 strain
and we can see that these two mouse
three bladder and mouse one bladder they
were negative from both
qpcr and also unbiased sequencing
are both detectable
uh from pbd capsuit and this particular
sample even has a very good
depth and
breadth of coverage
so the next experiment was to
demonstrate the um
utility of dvd capsic and ticks and
detection of agents other than borrelia
burgdorferi so in order to do that we
used 18 individual ticks and two tick
pools so there were ten exodus
scapularis adultics five exotic
scapularis nymphs three derma central
variable sticks two pools of amblyoma
americanum and each of these sticks were
infected with one two or three agents
and they were previously screened using
qpcr
or ultra or unbiased high throughput
sequencing
so
after sequencing the reeds were put
through filtration lenovo assembly and
homology search using blast
the samples had already gone through
more than three freeze thought cycles
prior to tbd capsid so we were not
really expecting great results
and despite that the full increase range
from 24 to 74 fold for the five
exodus capillaries pathogens
which we will see in the next slide and
we were able to generate complete genome
sequences for pravas and virus from two
tick samples and a 22 kb
borealia multi chromosomal context we
also detected other closely related
species that are
not detectable from unbiased sequencing
so uh
these are the first 10 samples from this
experiment
we don't have the data for unbiased
sequencing but we do have the data from
pcr from the for these samples
and we can see that anything that was
called positive from pcr is also called
positive from dvd capseek in addition to
the positive from the tbd capsic
from
qpcr tbd capsi can also identify
additional pathogens so it is
very good at identifying co-infections
and multiple infections uh
with high sensitivity because the read
counts are pretty good and we can see
that
the enrichment is pretty high
these are the next 10 samples uh
and we we don't have
the
the unbiased data for these samples but
for this set of samples we have both
qpcr data as well as the unbiased
sequencing data and we can see that dvds
capsic did really well
in terms of detecting the reads for
mapping to borrelia
and also other pathogens
as well as we can see here in the
parenthesis
that the fold enrichment is pretty good
so this experiment also did pretty
very well in detecting
more than one type of pathogen
and pathogens other than borrelia were
dorphy
the next experiment was to establish
limit of detection
and uh
for that we used borrelia burgdorferi
and bezier microtea samples
we quantified the pathogen and serially
diluted them
in sterile human blood to generate 10
fold dilutions
and for both the agents we were able to
get 90 genome recovery when we had
greater than 5000 copies and 25 percent
genome recovery at 1000 genomic copies
for the bezier micro t samples
for 1 to 10 genomic copies we recovered
almost like 1000 kv of sequence from
each of the four chromosomes
and for
the bolilla burgdorferi
mappings
are summarized here we can see that
the qpcr values are listed here
and the
read counts filtered reads and the reads
map and the percentage of leads map are
listed in these rows
we can see that
as the
qpcr values are increasing
we are still able to detect uh
the
the borilia bergdorferi
reads
at a qpcr value of 39.84
and even with one dilution
one smaller dilution we are able to
detect uh borrelia
correctly
and these for for these particular
dilutions these are leads mapped to
ribosomal rna so these are not uh
accu and these are not the boliga reads
but what we can see here is that at very
high
qpcr values the ct values
and the ones and the samples that are
not detectable from qpcr can be detected
with tb with dvd cap c so it has really
high sensitivity and it does a good job
of detecting
uh pathogens at low uh
when the
pathogen burden is very low
so uh we continued with validation and
clinical specimens
and
we
in this particular experiment we
demonstrate the performance of dbd
capsic on pathogens present in human
blood cells with acured by bc uses
so we took 14 whole blood samples from
patients diagnosed with
acute babies uses
and five samples that were post
treatment follow-up visit
and we found remarkable enrichment of
babies here reads
and eighty-one to ninety-nine percent of
the reads mapped to the bc microtea
and the assembled complete genome
sequence of the four chromosomes from
each of these samples could be obtained
there were three samples
with lobezia loads
and the follow-up samples were negative
and from these samples we obtained
almost like 100 babesia non-ribosomal
rna reads
so in the next
experiment which is also validation in
clinical samples we took 18 blood
samples from patients
with erythema migrants or acute babies
uses
and
all of these samples were negative by
ozcqpcr
and only two of these were correctly
identified so this table here shows uh
at the bottom here are the
samples uh the babies samples
which are
like really strongly positive and we can
see that there's a bias of the reads
distribution where most of the reads are
assigned to these two babies
samples
and the other samples ended up getting
fewer reads
we can see that the bezia
is identified with very high confidence
the number of breeds assigned to babesia
is very high
but
all of these
samples from uh
lyme disease here are negative only two
samples were correctly identified but
they are not part of this table they are
uh
there's a separate table which is
present in the paper
so uh
even with
all the negative samples we were able to
accurately identify two samples
and we were
very successful in um
in uh
verbeta diagnosis with this sample set
so the conclusions from this um are
that we were able to demonstrate the
simultaneous detection and genotyping of
tick bond pathogen and disease agents in
a wide range of samples
and we can see that tbd capsic is
markedly superior to unbiased sequencing
and it exceeded the sensitivity of qpcr
it can be further improved with
modifications to sample preparation and
sequencing protocols
and increasing sequencing depth may also
increase the sensitivity
and it can offer valuable insights into
our understanding of tick-borne diseases
by facilitating analysis of previously
undiagnosed samples
the next part of my talk is uh
about where capsic vertebrate it's a
virum capture sequencing assay similar
to tbd capsic
this was actually published in 2015
and
it's
very well
cited by um in other articles and
i'm only going to scratch the surface in
this partic for this particular uh
section of my talk
given the time
constraint
but for more information you can check
out this article and there are several
other articles that talk about this
essay
so this uh slide here shows the
design process and the validation
process for this um
for wakatseek vertebrate rc so first the
probes were designed and in order to
design the probes we downloaded all the
viral coding sequences from embl
database we designed the probes and from
there we designed a unique probe set
then the probes were validated by
mapping against 100 representative
genomes to see that the probes are
mapping to these genomes
ubiquitously and also they map only to
vertebrate viruses not to plant viruses
or insect viruses or bacteriophages
and after pro in silicon validation
uh we did a probe
probe synthesis where the tm was
adjusted homopolymeric sequences were
removed and were trimmed and the probes
were synthesized on class slide
using a glass slide
method
so
after the pros were synthesized the
probes were tested with simulated
samples to look for specificity
sensitivity and to compare the results
with rt pcr
and also to see the performance in
multiplexing and to see if probes get
saturated or not
and after that the
results were extended to real samples
uh
using it to see how well it performs
when applied in a real realistic
scenario
so the first step
that i mentioned which is the in silico
validation that was performed on 100
genomes
here is an example showing only three
genomes and we can see that
when probes are mapped to the
genomes of poliovirus or yellow fever
virus or parvovirus we see pretty good
coverage which is ubiquitous
uh however we see the difference in the
depth of the
probes because
some
sequences are over represented in the
databases
and they result in higher number of
probes and also
some parts of the genome are more
diverse than the others
and they result in higher number of
probes but overall it's a good
representation because we see that the
genomes are
fully covered in the coding regions
so the first experiment in this uh
particular
uh
validation
was to compare unbiased with bulkapc
vertebrate there were two pools here the
first pool consisted of these three
viruses
and pool two consisted of these four
viruses the first pool used lung
background and the second pool consisted
of blood background
each pool was
run with unbiased and were catholic
sequencing using illumina high feek and
there were two replicate runs for each
experiment
so the results from this experiment are
summarized here we can see uh that
these are the results using unbiased
sequencing and these are the results
with capture sequencing
and we can see that the number of map
reads for each of the viruses is
significantly greater
capture sequencing than without for all
the
agents in this particular experiment
and the fold increase is
pretty high and we are seeing up to 8
000 fold increase in the average
coverage
so uh here we can see uh a schematic
showing the enrichment basically this is
the unbiased sequencing this is where
cathy vertebrate and this is the mapping
of the probe to the genome and here we
can see that uh capture sequencing has
done a pretty good job
of mapping the reads to the
to the reference genome and whereas the
conventional sequencing is pretty sparse
and it's
not that
like they're not doing that well
similarly for this particular uh
enterovirus genome
so
this shows the specificity of recap seek
so
uh here we can see
uh
the pools
where basically
these are the reads before a host
removal and after host removal and when
you compare the conventional method to
uh
recap seek you can see that
uh recap c gives you higher number of
reads after whole subtraction as
compared to the regular method and in
the second pool
it's similar that we get more number of
uh
reads after whole subtraction and also
we can see the percent of host removed
is
much less with uh recursive than with
the
regular unbiased sequencing showing that
recapsic has high specificity
now in terms of the limit of detection
uh
here we can see uh that
there are two experiments in blood and
lung
and we can see the copy numbers ranging
from
like very low of 10 to 5000
and we can see that with copy numbers as
low as 10
we have some detection
and at a copy number of 30 we have
pretty good recovery like almost ranging
from 20 to 30 percent
in blood and in lung we are also seeing
like almost like 5 to 20 percent of
genome because we have 30 copy number
but even with lower copy numbers there's
still some detection showing that it's
very sensitive
and
this particular uh result shows that
it's even more sensitive than rdpcr
so here we can see um
the entire virus in uh
basically using the standard
conventional method and also using uh
where capseq and here we can see that
the serum in the
where cat seek is performing much better
than the standard serum and also the
where capsic
blood is performing much better than the
standard blood
and overall serum is performing better
than
blood and similar for
hv1 and these are the detection limits
using qpcr but we can see that with
recapsic vertebrate at much lower copy
numbers we have significant detection
showing that it's much more sensitive
than rdpcr
and this is the experiment where we used
these uh set of viruses
in blood background and we did a seven
plex lane with fifty thousand copies and
a twenty one plex lane where
there were three sets of samples
which had 500 copies for each of these
uh seven agents
fifty thousand copies and also
uh
set three had copies ranging from three
thousand to ten million so the idea here
is to see
if 21 plex uh gives a similar results as
seven plus flex and that increasing the
multiplexing
uh affects the results or not
and here are the results and we can see
that
with low multiplexing
and high multiplexing at 50 000 copies
the results are quite similar
and even with 500 copies
uh the results are
pretty good like we are still able to
detect all of these
genomes
uh with a good sensitivity so
even with the 21 plex experiment we were
able to
identify the
viruses correctly and since we had
different levels of probes in the
experiment it did not lead to
[Music]
the saturation of the probes
so the confusion so far are
uh
wilcap seek vertibit showed up to
thousand-fold increase in reads mapped
to eight candidate viruses
it had higher sensitivity than
conventional pre-processed samples
and it showed higher sensitivity
and specificity
and
with significant reduction in host
background
it had lower limit of detection than
real-time pcr
and it performed well with higher
multiplexing and probe saturation was
not observed
so then we proceeded to validation with
real samples using two case studies so
one was bad feces sampled with rotavirus
and one was dear mouse sample uh
with a novel hepati virus that was
already obtained using uh
raised pcr in the lab
so with the
bad feces samples we can see that even
without uh
no treatment capture sequencing did much
better with than the conventional assay
where we had applied pretreatment and
the dns treatment
and
9 out of 11 genomic segments of
rotaviruses could be recovered
and two missing rotavirus segments
could be partially recovered with
vitrapseq
and it also recovered partial genomes
for other viruses that were not seen in
unbiased or the conventional sequencing
and the insect viruses were reduced in
and contrast to conventional
and here is the result for a noble
hypothy virus we can see that we were
able to get pretty good coverage with
unbiased sequencing we were not able to
recover this
and had very few reads but here we can
see that even with no treatment we have
49 leads that were mapped and there is a
detection of
uh almost like 17 000
1781 bases
so currently we have uh
moved from nimblegen to twist platform
and we modified the probes and this
table just shows the comparison between
them belgium and twist platforms but i'm
not going to get into the details of
this
but uh just want to mention that it has
been successfully applied to several
small and large projects
and the probes have been redesigned
using longer problems using swiss
platform and the clear approval for this
particular
system is underway
and there are several publications out
there that support this particular
system and if you're interested you can
check it out
and i would like to end by saying
a big thanks to rafal from cii
and their other or the entire team who
has been involved in both
dvd capseek and as well as
recapseeq
and i would like to thank you for your
time thanks